Welcome and thank you for joining us as we explore Reza Shakhazemi's spiritual ethos, looking closely at the Imam's letter to a governor bound for Egypt and a profound claim at its center.
Justice is not fairness.
It is the very nature of God.
So to be just is to become like God while remaining wholly his slave.
We are really stepping into the deep spiritual architecture of governance today because we are confronting this deeply unsettling reality
that political tyranny doesn't actually begin on a battlefield.
It doesn't begin in the courtroom either.
It starts inward.
Like an invisible disease.
Exactly.
An invisible fatal disease of the soul called pride.
The crisis we face when discussing this in the modern world is that our ordinary speech shrinks justice down to mere fairness.
I mean, we treat it like a set of administrative rules, you know, just fair play.
We do.
We reduce it to legal compliance, a secular function for just keeping the peace.
The philosopher McIntyre diagnosed this condition perfectly when he charged that ethics, once it is cut from the good, drifts entirely into relativism and dead forms.
We are left with a system of rules that has no underlying anchor in transcendent reality.
Which really leaves us looking at a body without a spirit.
Fairness, when you strip away its sacred dimension, acts as the lifeless shell of a sacred thing.
You can prop it up, you can...
dress it in legal statutes.
You can even make it look like it is functioning perfectly in some massive bureaucracy, but it has no animating breath.
It is a hollow performance.
It really is.
And the tension at the center of the imam's letter reveals how a simple, private feeling of superiority, just feeling better than a subordinate, is actually a covert declaration of war against the creator.
True justice cannot exist without profound personal poverty.
So to understand the ground we are standing on, we have to look at the three-part framework the tradition offers for human spiritual life.
Right, the first part being submission.
Submission gives us the outward acts, the formal structures of how we behave and interact with the physical world.
And then the second part is faith, which provides the internal framework, the conviction, the intellectual assent to reality.
But their union, the third part, is spiritual excellence.
Spiritual excellence is what gives that entire structure life and breath.
The tradition defines this spiritual excellence so beautifully.
It says, it is to worship God as though you see Him and if you see Him not, yet truly He sees you.
That specific definition always brings to mind the famous tradition of the stranger who questions the Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family.
The story paints such a striking image.
It really does.
A stranger, his clothes perfectly white and his hair intensely black with no signs of travel upon him, just walks into the gathering.
He sits down, bringing his knees directly against the prophet's knees.
And he begins to question him about submission, then about faith, and finally about spiritual excellence.
And when the prophet answers with that exact definition, to worship is though you see him,
The stranger confirms the answer.
Yes, by confirming it, the stranger is disclosing to everyone present what spiritual excellence truly is.
The tradition later reveals the stranger was Gabriel, teaching the community their religion through the very act of asking questions.
Fascinating.
And in the light of that profound spiritual awareness, justice takes on an entirely different weight.
Justice becomes the act of putting everything in its right and proper place, not just outwardly in human society, but inwardly in the landscape of the human soul.
Which brings us directly to the warning the imam, peace be upon him, gives to the governor sent to Egypt.
He identifies pride as the very root of injustice.
He completely refuses to treat pride as just a bad mood or an unattractive personality trait or some psychological defense mechanism.
He defines it as a literal misappropriation of a divine attribute.
Introduces a terrifying divine saying at the center of this teaching.
It says, pride is my cloak and greatness is my robe.
Whoever contends with me over either of them, I shall cast him into the fire.
The imagery there is immense.
Well, I don't buy that yet, to be honest.
Calling an arrogant boss or a high-handed local politician someone who is literally at war with God sounds like a massive mythological exaggeration.
I mean, is this not just a horizontal crime against fellow humans?
I see why you would ask that.
If a manager steals credit for a project or a governor mistreats a citizen, the harm is happening horizontally between two people walking on the earth.
How does this framework justify elevating A mundane human failing into a cosmic theological battle?
That is a crucial question.
But the spiritual physics of the situation reveal a completely different reality than what we see on the surface.
Downward arrogance is, by its very nature, upward rebellion.
Let us look closely at the imagery of the cloak and the robe.
The regalia of a king.
Precisely.
They are what the sovereign wears to signify absolute majesty.
They are never shared.
They are never lent out.
And they are certainly never to be worn by a subject standing inside the king's own hall.
The reason this is considered literal theft is based on the absolute difference between the creator and the created.
Because God is the proud since his greatness is underived.
It is absolute.
It is simply the truth of what he is.
A human being, on the other hand, owns absolutely nothing.
So every single faculty a person possesses their intelligence, their political power, their physical strength, their very existence from one heartbeat to the next.
Completely.
Taking pride in a loan, behaving as though the borrowed material is your own inherent possession is a profound and dangerous delusion.
A loyal subject acknowledges, in their very bearing, that the greatness in the room belongs entirely to the sovereign.
They defer.
They keep their proper place.
But a subject who parades in the king's robe inside the king's hall?
Displaying a majesty they do not actually possess.
They are openly denying the king's supremacy.
Oppression toward those below you is just the visible earthly symptom of forgetting who actually holds dominion in the heavens.
The imam teaches that horizontal injustice is animated by an invisible, toxic substance, which is enmity toward transcendent reality.
The letter notes that the corrupt ruler has forgotten a specific, immediate reality to whom belongs the dominion this day.
It isn't just about fearing a future day of judgment.
The proud person behaves as though the sovereignty of the present moment, this very afternoon in the office or the state house, belongs to them.
They have claimed the center of the universe for themselves.
To see the full anatomy of this specific error, the Imam directs the governor to the historical and spiritual archetype of this vice in a famous discourse known as the Sermon of the Abasement.
He points back to the dawn of creation, to the first arrogant one.
When the command was given to the angels to prostrate before the newly fashioned human being, the entire company obeyed, save one.
The tradition explains that a vehement passion overcame his intellect.
He deemed himself superior on a ground that felt entirely self-evident, entirely logical to him.
He was made of fire and Adam was merely made of clay.
Fire against clay.
He took a mere difference in material composition and converted it into a claim of superiority.
And that claim of superiority then crystallized into an open defiance of a direct divine command.
This exact anatomy of pride infects human societies every single day.
We take a mere difference, our wealth, our educational background, our zip code, our skin color, or even our strict religious observance, and we convert that difference into superiority.
And then that superiority becomes an excuse to defy the command to treat the other person with dignity.
The insidious nature of this disease is how quietly it operates.
The prophet offered a terrifying analogy for how this hidden idol worship creeps into the human soul.
The black ant on the dark rock.
Yes.
He warned that it is more hidden than the creeping of a black ant over a hard rock on a dark night.
The superficial ancient notion of idolatry is bowing down to a physical statue made of wood or stone.
But the hidden, much more dangerous form is the worship of the self, concealed deep within our own intentions, our quiet attitudes, and our unspoken assumptions about our own worth.
The letter explores this quiet idolatry through the concept of pretension, you know, doing virtuous acts specifically to be seen by others.
When someone performs a charity or speaks eloquently about justice but does so merely to win the applause of their peers, they are setting up a rival God.
The audience's approval becomes the deity they're actually worshiping.
And the chilling consequence laid out in the teaching is that God simply hands the performer over to the humans they performed for.
The person is left with exactly what they saw, the fleeting, fragile, admiring gaze of their peers and absolutely nothing more.
The divine presence withdraws.
The profound irony is that the person engaging in this pretension may perform outward acts of virtue with scrupulous, exhausting care.
They might appear incredibly devout, tirelessly generous, or fiercely dedicated to social causes.
Yet they never suspect that the true recipient of all that exhausting worship is their own reputation.
The imam presses the point that the first arrogant one, the creature of fire, was ultimately humiliated through his own pride.
The proud person imagines they are building a towering monument to themselves.
But the very act of self-exaltation is the gravity that casts them down.
Self-aggrandizement is self-destruction dressed up as glory.
That mechanism really highlights a deep paradox in the spiritual life.
The tradition states, the sin that grieves you is better in the sight of God than the virtue that makes you proud.
A sin that shatters your ego, that brings you to your knees in genuine tears of regret, keeps you in the right relation to reality.
You remember you are poor and in need.
Whereas A virtue that quietly inflates your ego, a charity that makes you feel superior to the person you're helped, reverses that relationship.
Excessive praise, both the praise we seek and the praise we receive, is actually a weapon that effaces genuine virtue.
And when we move from the cosmic archetype of arrogance to the mundane psychology of the human tyrant,
the danger becomes fiercely practical.
The imam pinpoints the exact, seemingly harmless sentence that starts a ruler's slide into oppression.
He warns the governor against ever saying to himself, I order and am obeyed.
It sounds like a simple, neutral observation of administrative fact.
A leader gives a command and the staff carries it out.
But the imam insists that entertaining this very thought causes an immediate corruption in the heart first and the erosion of religion second.
The sequence is the entire diagnosis.
The rot begins invisibly on the inside in the ruler's relationship to their own borrowed authority, long before it ever touches their outward practice of faith or their public policy.
The linguistic connection in the classical Arabic tradition is fascinating here.
The word for arrogance springs from the exact same root as the word for imagination.
Pride is classified not just as a moral failing, but as an intellectual defect.
It is an active hallucination.
An active hallucination.
Yes, it is a delusion where a person manages to inflate their sense of self only by drastically shrinking their perception of the real.
The arrogant person overrates themselves only because they have first, tragically, underrated the absolute.
The swelling of the human ego is the exact measure of how small reality has grown in their sight.
I have to challenge this framework again.
How is this different from any virtue we're told to imitate?
And furthermore, if a tyrant is getting richer and their borders are expanding, how does this framework convince anyone they are actually failing?
I mean, if a governor's orders are being obeyed, if their wealth is multiplying, every earthly metric we have says they are succeeding.
Why would they ever believe they are suffering from an intellectual defect?
Your challenge touches on the terrifying theological concept of gradual ruin.
a punishment drawn out by imperceptible degrees.
The free work the imam provides overturns every worldly measure of success we rely on.
So success is actually a trap.
Worldly success, expanding wealth and consolidated power can actually be a highly sophisticated trap.
The tradition teaches that a spiritual punishment can be administered gradually, stage upon stage, without the person ever perceiving it.
A continuous, uninterrupted prosperity that slowly hardens the soul is the slow, silent closing of a trap.
That is chilling.
This is why a ruler can look formally devout, bearing the name of a believer, holding magnificent titles while being spiritually ruinous on the inside.
They fit the strict, classical meaning of one who covers over the truth.
They are burying beneath their layers of arrogance and wealth the fundamental reality they were created to acknowledge.
Which brings us to the pivot of our entire discussion.
Justice is not merely 1 divine attribute sitting on a list alongside others.
It is God's very essence.
The imam states clearly, I bear witness that he is justice and he acts justly.
That is the core of it.
To steel man the objection I raised earlier, one might argue that infinite divine justice, which is flawless, absolute and beyond time, cannot
possibly be the same word or the same reality as human striving, which is messy, flawed, contingent, and constantly making mistakes.
How can the flawless nature of the creator be equated with the compromise
exhausted attempts of a human ruler trying to organize a flawed society.
The answer the text provides is that humans striving for justice is that exact same principle operating under a creature's fragile conditions.
Justice in the heavens becomes conscience on the earth.
Justice is not fairness.
It is the very nature of God.
So to be just is to become like God while remaining wholly his slave.
If the outward war of oppression is actually a war against reality itself, we have to ask,
Where is the front line of that war fought?
The text tells us the front line is entirely inside the human soul.
The ruler must first violently defeat their own conscience before they can ever oppress a single citizen in the street.
We really need to draw a sharp contrast between the modern secular view of conscience and the imam's view.
Secular ethics generally treats conscience as a private, socially constructed sense of right and wrong.
Like A byproduct of one's culture, evolutionary biology, or childhood upbringing.
It is entirely subjective.
Views conscience as a divine infusion, a permanent trace of the Creator woven into the very making of the human soul.
The soul does not arrive in this world as a blank slate.
It arrives already inscribed with profound primordial capacity to recognize the fundamental difference between wickedness and righteousness.
The tradition explores this through the concept of the primordial covenant.
There is a moment outside of our normal perception of time at the dawn of things.
where the human soul was asked a single question, am I not your Lord?
And every soul testified to that reality.
Spiritual consciousness, knowing deep in your bones your dependence on the Creator, breeds moral conscience.
To ignore that inner voice when it tells you an action is wrong is to attack the very root of your own soul.
It is denying the primordial reality that there is any lord to whom you owe in accounting.
And this introduces the concept of the soul that incites the evil.
This is the appetitive reactive self that issues endless demands for comfort, status, and control, and demands to be obeyed.
When the human tyrant says, I order and am obeyed to a nation, they have already surrendered to this lower self inward.
The lower soul gave an order for power or wealth.
And the rest of the person's faculties, their bright intellect, their vast imagination, their iron will, all meekly fell into line and obeyed.
The political tyranny outside is merely a loud, destructive projection of a tyranny already firmly established within the silent borders of the leader's own mind.
This realization changes the entire nature of the text we are reading.
It turns the letter from a medieval manual for kings into a mirror for you and me.
The difference between a brutal dictator and someone who casually overrides their conscience at work to secure an unearned promotion is merely a matter of scale and opportunity.
The mechanics of the internal surrender, the silencing of the divine trace to serve the ego are identical.
Because the disease begins within, the antidote must also begin within.
The letter points relentlessly to the reform of the self as the primary duty of governance.
The Imam insists that trying to reform a broken society while your own soul is corrupt is the greatest of faults.
It inverts the fundamental order of repair.
You cannot put things in the right place in the material world if you have not first put yourself in the right place before reality.
The text grounds this in a stark principle, O mankind, ye are the poor before God.
Before the absolute, every human being is entirely destitute.
The vast wealth a ruler commands, the armies at their disposal, the treasuries they unlock, none of it constitutes their own richness.
It is all borrowed against an absolute ontological poverty they share equally with a beggar sleeping at their gate.
The imam's legendary historical austerity embodied this principle in flesh and blood.
He possessed ultimate political authority, yet he wore rough clothing, ate course food, and completely refused the comforts that others in his position assumed were their natural right.
There is an illuminating anecdote about an ascetic named Asim who had thrown himself into severe, punishing self-denial, cutting himself off from his family and ordinary life.
The imam summoned him and told him not to deny himself the good, lawful things of the world.
And the ascetic, confused,
challenged the imam, pointing aggressively at the imam's own rough, patched clothes and coarse bread.
The imam's brilliant distinction in that moment changes everything about how we are supposed to view leadership.
He replied that private asceticism undertaken by a regular citizen is a personal indulgence, sometimes even a trap for the ego.
But the leaders of the truth, those holding authority, have a sacred duty to proportion their own lifestyle to the weakest and poorest among the people.
By living exactly like the poorest citizens, the ruler actively removes the psychological sting of poverty.
No poor person looking at their leader feels the unique, bitter pain of a comfort they cannot share.
The private aesthetic's denial is turned inward toward the self, perhaps even breeding its own kind of hidden pride.
Another black ant on a dark rock.
The leader's austerity, however, is turned entirely outward as an act of solidarity toward the people.
It is a material manifestation of their attachment to the real, in whose blinding light material wealth does not register as wealth at all.
By refusing the false, fleeting richness of the world, the ruler claims the real richness, holding their life on the exact same terms as their weakest subject.
There is a beautiful parable from an early Sufi master that perfectly captures the mechanics of this necessary detachment.
The master speaks of a man knocking on the door of the beloved.
The voice inside the house asks, who is there?
The man answers, it is I.
The door remains firmly shut.
He's still full of himself.
Exactly.
Or rather, he hasn't let go of his ego.
The man goes away, wanders in the desert, undergoes profound spiritual transformation and returns years later to knock again.
The voice inside asks, who is there?
This time the man answers, it is thou, and the door instantly opens.
True detachment is emptying the self to let the real enter.
The door to true justice does not open to a self that arrives full of its own importance.
And this profound self-lowering is not just about maintaining personal purity or ascetic credibility.
It builds the very structural foundation for how the ruler treats others.
It leads directly to the implementation of compassion in society.
We really must correct a massive modern misconception here.
We tend to think of justice and mercy as pulling in opposite directions.
We view justice as the stern, unyielding enforcer of rules and mercy as the soft, emotional bending of those rules.
But the text insists that mercy is justice when it aligns with the nature of God, the infinitely compassionate, the ever merciful.
The divine law is stated with absolute clarity.
My mercy takes precedence over my wrath.
Spiritual arithmetic dictates that dispensing mercy to those below brings down divine mercy from above.
You cannot beg for forgiveness and leniency from the absolute while ruthlessly withholding it from the fragile people under your control.
Yet we must look very closely at how this mercy manifests in reality.
It does not mean softness.
It does not mean letting corruption slide.
The rigorous side of things is subordinated to mercy, but it is not abolished by it.
The imam famously ordered severe corporal punishment for officers found misappropriating public funds.
He swore absolute retribution to deputies who enriched themselves at the people's expense.
The mercy is deeply real, but so is the iron.
Wait, how can a leader claim their heart is infused with mercy if they are willing to hold a red hot iron to their own blind brother?
The historical accounts detail a shocking moment where the imam's brother, who was blind and living in genuine poverty, came to him requesting just a little excess from the public funds to feed his family.
And the imam's response was terrifying.
He heated a piece of iron until it was glowing red and held it near his brother's body, warning him that taking unearned wealth from the public treasury would lead to a far more terrible eternal fire.
He also threatened his own cousin with the sword for misusing state funds, stating on the record he wouldn't spare the prophet's own grandsons if they stole.
It is an undeniably harsh, terrifying image.
It forcefully challenges our modern sentimental sensibilities of what compassion is supposed to look like.
However, the synthesis the text provides resolves this profound tension.
Nepotism wearing justice's clothes is the ultimate tyranny.
Protecting the public treasury, which belongs to the widows, the orphans and the destitute, is the ultimate act of mercy for the community as a whole.
Bending the rules for a family member, no matter how much you love them, steals directly from the collective survival of the weakest.
The frightening severity directed toward the brother and the cousin is the exact mathematical measure of the imam's fierce mercy toward the anonymous destitute who rely on those public funds to survive.
Justice that bends for one's own people.
Justice that has a VIP lane for family is not justice at all.
I see.
I have to concede that point, actually.
The severity toward the brother is the exact measure of mercy toward the destitute who rely on those funds.
That structural integrity brings us to the grand culmination of the imam's letter regarding humanity as a whole.
He instructs the governor to infuse his heart with mercy, love, and kindness for all the subjects under his rule, giving one specific soaring reason.
for they are of two types, either your brother in religion or your like in creation.
That single sentence completely dismantles any attempt to build a hierarchy of civic care based on shared belief.
The people governed are either bound to the ruler by the ties of faith or they are bound to the ruler by the sheer undeniable fact of being created beings.
There is no third category.
None.
No human being falls outside the reach of the ruler's absolute obligation to provide justice, safety, and mercy.
The story of the imam encountering the old blind Christian beggar perfectly illustrates this universal vision.
The imam was walking through the marketplace and saw an elderly man of a different faith begging for scraps.
The imam was furious.
He rebuked the community leaders.
He pointed out the gross hypocrisy that they had eagerly used the man's labor and extracted his strength when he was young, only to abandon him to the street in his old age.
He immediately ordered that the man receive a permanent, dignified pension from the public treasury.
In that single decisive directive, the imam established the principle of universal social welfare untethered from religious discrimination.
The beggar's theology was not the cauldron.
His fragile humanity was.
He was alike in creation, and that biological and spiritual fact was a complete and sufficient claim on the community's resources.
This principle echoes across the centuries.
We see it living today when figures like the Aga Khan emphasize that a faith proves its vitality and truth through the structural compassion it extends to the whole of humanity.
The true, undeniable health of any society is always read at its weakest, most marginalized edges.
To connect this entire incredible journey, we started by looking at the Erican tyrant, stealing the cloak of greatness and declaring an invisible, doomed war on reality.
We trace the front lines of that war inward to the deliberate silencing of the conscience, the quiet surrender to the soul it incites to evil demanding to be obeyed.
We then saw the radical antidote in the self-lowering of the leader who recognizes their absolute poverty before the Creator.
And finally, from that lowered, grounded place, we witnessed the rise of a compassion so fierce it would threaten a brother with ******* iron, and yet so gentle it would systematically feed and protect a beggar of a different faith.
Justice is fundamentally an inside-out job.
The daily, exhausting disciplines of refusing pride, of killing the ego, and of listening to the quiet whisper of conscience are not merely exercises in private therapeutic self-help.
They are the exact, required blueprints to build a political society where the most vulnerable are fiercely protected.
To be just is to actively assume the character traits of God, to be wildly generous because he is the generous, to be relentlessly merciful because he is the merciful.
But the crucial, terrifying condition is never, ever claiming those traits as your own possession.
You act as an inverted image in a mirror.
The mirror catches the light and reflects it perfectly into the dark corners of the room, but the mirror itself is just polished glass.
It generates absolutely no light of its own.
You are entirely effaced as God's slave, yet you are reflecting the divine majesty as God's vicejourn on earth.
Justice is not fairness.
It is the very nature of God.
So to be just is to become like God while remaining wholly his slave.
This immense framework leaves us with a necessary, perhaps uncomfortable, interrogation of our own daily lives.
We must actively look for the black ant on the dark rock in our own conduct.
We have to ruthlessly examine the subtle, quiet ways we might be wearing the cloak of pride.
Perhaps by performing our virtues, our politics, or our charities for an audience of our peers, seeking their validation rather than aligning ourselves with the real.
Which divine trait have you been withholding from the people around you this week?
What small daily whisper of your conscience have you been silencing just to win a temporary advantage at work or in a relationship?
And most importantly, what would facing your ego actually cost you if you decided to start listening to that inner voice again tomorrow morning?
We leave you with those questions to carry with you.
Thank you for joining us on this deep dive.